thank you
hey everybody what's going on what's
that look like I'm over in a video next
door you're in the video next door yeah
you're in the same spot as usual I'm in
the same spot as usual okay it's just
because I tell you this every single day
yeah yeah it's just because I don't have
I don't have I I have to tell he doesn't
have any like memory I have the [ __ ]
agency to comprehend he's like the
panoramic view he's like the Memento
dude like you have to tell them new
things like you have to tell them the
same thing like every day because he
forgets everything moment to Dude
Where's the moment to do
it was the dude uh it was that movie
about the guy that couldn't form any uh
new memories like any shorts or memories
so he had to like learn things like into
it
I'm just teasing you I'm just telling
you I have to tell you every day so um
we got to review one of my all-time
favorite movies since I was a kid I saw
the first saw this when I was a kid and
[ __ ] I loved it
was probably about 10 maybe eight nine
ten when I first saw it The Ghost and
Mrs Muir from 1947.
it's a good flick is it like a
paranormal
Romance
Gothic paranormal romance kind of yeah
yeah it starts off kind of scary you
think it's going to be a horror movie
but then it starts getting real cool
it's kind of where
it's kind of like I think it inspired
the movie Ghost later on that's what I
was thinking while we were watching it
although I'm gonna say uh I liked ghosts
but I I liked this a lot better yeah it
was a lot better this was actually I
think I saw this when I was a kid but I
didn't really because I remembered a
couple scenes from it just in kind of
broken things but I guess I don't know I
guess it didn't make much of an
impression but like seeing it again I'm
like this is a delightful film it's
delightful yeah it was it was just
awesome it's it's a it's the
cinematography is beautiful the acting
is awesome like it's funny it's like way
funnier and like the way Wittier
actually Wittier is the worst yeah I
wouldn't call it funny it's not funny
it's witty like the script is very witty
yeah and there there is some humor in it
but that's that's after kind of like the
horror elements get out of the way
because
it's about this woman she's a widow
she's got a girl and a she's got her
maid they're in England
and her in-laws
with the mother-in-law and the
sister-in-law
don't want her moving out on her own
those two yeah yeah we'll talk about
that this is in the Victorian era all
right yeah it's like it's supposed to be
like the turn of the century so I guess
it's like 1900 1901 okay so early 20th
century I'm pretty sure it said 12th
century she gets there in a car it looks
like it looks like a very early 1900s
car then later her daughter shows up
later in a 1920s car and she's all kind
of an Old Woman by that time so yeah the
1910 probably
uh anyway I got sidetracked there
her in-laws don't want her moving out of
the house and living her own life really
they want her to stay there and it's
going to be just these three girls and
she's not really related to the the two
women she wants to live her own life and
they're telling her how insane it is
that a woman wants to live her own life
imagine that yeah I think a lot of it
had to do with uh them wanting her money
because she was getting some she was
getting commissions from this uh gold
mine that she had inherited and so she
was getting you know like shares she had
shares and yeah she was getting like
little that was her income that was her
income
and um
so she goes to a real estate agent and
you know they got this goofy dude there
trying to pick houses out for her and
she goes I want this one she's looking
at one you know yeah go Cottage he's
like oh no that's totally unsuitable for
you and she's like she keep she's not
letting herself you know pushed around
by these dudes you know she's I love her
characters she is so awesome in this
yeah she is just not having it yeah I
don't know this taxes names but she's
just jeans jeans here because she's very
very famous she's super cute she kind of
reminds me a lot of like uh Lucille Ball
the way she looks she looked like look
kind of like Lucille Ball Gene Tierney
she was she was known for being like one
of the most beautiful women at the time
yeah
um also she was in probably best known
for the movie Laura did she get an Oscar
nomination for that I feel like that's
something Zach would know but I can't
like really remember but she was in a
ton of stuff to me she looks a lot like
Lucille Ball Lucille's Lucille Ball
smoking hot she was super hot yeah
um you don't notice it because she's
funny yeah
yeah so anyway
she goes um another another thing about
Lucille Ball is that she was super smart
she was like running all kinds of Studio
stuff and she did a lot of [ __ ] she's a
super competent woman
anyway
um real estate agent takes her to the
house go Cottage and it's all [ __ ] up
it's like something my [ __ ] know uh
off of [ __ ] a haunting episode it's
like Summerwind
but it's it's like Summer Wind in the
episode not the way someone really
looked yeah because the inside looks
okay like the outside looks a little bit
dumpy but not too bad she can't believe
it's so cheap and it's fully furnished
yeah and uh the dude says this house is
just not suitable for you you know she
goes well what happened to the house
because it was built by a sea captain
well and and and because he died because
he committed suicide and she's like oh
oh that's [ __ ] up yeah she said go in
there and and it's a spooky looking
house but it's real nice it's like
something out of it's kind of like a
hammer horror type looking and
um it's kind of a Victorian two-story
house it's got balconies it's got a damn
brass telescope so the captain could
look over the bay and
furnishings and paintings of the captain
and the painting inside the painting of
the captain and there's you know it's
Rex Harrison you know it's kind of he's
kind of smirking being like yes [ __ ]
cat was weird that's awesome yeah
that's what I was thinking yeah yeah
yeah you know I'm [ __ ] hot
she's doing that you know and she's
looking at all right and we'll um
ghost tries to chase him out they did
they did run out
um
and then the real estate agents see this
is what I was talking about I did you
know this house is [ __ ] terrifying
man you can't live there and she's and
she's like nah she's like I want that
[ __ ] I'm into it
she buys a haunted house
and that's where the adventure begins
and they're so there's a good 15 minutes
20 minutes A Haunted House kind of movie
and it kind of goes along a lot of the
haunted
uh tropes and it sets up good atmosphere
you're like damn you know you know by
the title that she gets to know this
ghost anyway goes yeah this is mirror so
and it's based on a novel I don't know
if you know that but yeah the novel had
come out two years before so Rex
Harrison materializes in the kitchen
after he was done [ __ ] with her kept
blowing out her candles and blowing out
she's like [ __ ] yeah
challenging her he's like I'm gonna
drive you out of this house this is my
house she's like the hell you are this
is my house yeah
so she's like well uh maybe we can work
something out and uh they kind of reach
an agreement he ends up kind of
letting her stay on a temporary basic
basis because she's taking care of the
house that she loves the house
and um also I think I um that he likes
how [ __ ] feisty she is yeah she
fights back because she's not having it
man she is just like well she is like
the best character because it's just
kind of like you know this is set in the
very early 20th century
where you know women didn't really have
a lot of agency and like I said she gets
uh her [ __ ] meddling mother-in-law
because her husband dies right she's a
widow so the meddling mother-in-law and
the meddling sister-in-law why would you
ever want to live by yourself it's like
why don't you stay here with your family
she was like look I'm not related to you
[ __ ] and I'm like and you guys are
[ __ ] all crawling up in my grill all
the time she's like [ __ ] this I want to
be on my own and she is just absolutely
not she's not obnoxious about it but she
absolutely is very assertive and she
just does not let anybody push her
around ever I mean she knows what she
wants and she's like and this is what's
gonna happen you know what I mean so
what happens later is that she ends up
being kind of like the caretaker
but this is evidently only a month or so
then she gets the bad news the in-laws
show up and they say by the way the the
Goldmine money is drying up the gold
mine went bust so you're gonna have to
move back with us
and bugging the ghost [ __ ] the ghost
of the captain's like oh no you tell
they have a [ __ ] shove off man
[ __ ] the [ __ ] them you know he didn't
like them either yeah nobody likes it
yeah he ended up chasing them out
and then um Miss Muir is like uh well I
don't know what I'm gonna do and he goes
well I got an idea he goes so you know
basically something's going to come up
we're going to figure something out
he comes up with something later I guess
it might have been the next day
he said you're going to write my life
story and we're gonna and and it's gonna
be about the lives of a [ __ ] of a sea
captain and how I grew up
and just say it's written by you know
blood and swash by Captain X blood and
squash
she's like okay if you think if you
think that'll work he says oh yeah it'll
it'll sell a [ __ ] ton and it'll he's
like oh I've lived a life I'm telling
you right I've lived a life yeah I lived
a man's life yeah and I'm not ashamed of
it that's what he said yeah
so there's a lot of like um they can't
say a lot of things out right I guess
between the lines but it's pretty clear
like what the implications of is like of
what he's saying and like some of the
stuff they said I was like whoa all
right yeah
[Laughter]
so then there's a part and then there's
uh several scenes in the movie where
they're staying up late and he's
dictating the book to her
and a lot of funny [ __ ] happens there
you know about over grammar they're
fighting over grammar
that sounds like something I would do so
I could totally relate to the girl you
know yeah and then he tells his last
story about he was he was an orphan if I
remember correctly because uh he was he
was an orphan and the vicar [ __ ]
educated him and then he says [ __ ] all
this [ __ ] he's kept me getting in
trouble so he goes to see
at 16 he loses his virginity at the
[ __ ] brothel at the Port yeah and
they don't say that but then it's very
very heavily and then all this other
[ __ ] happens and by the end of the book
when by the end you know okay the book
is finished
Mrs Muir is in love with him yeah this
ghost and he's in love with her yeah
yeah although I don't think he would
admit that necessarily
and he she can't touch him and he'll
dematerialize it all right so she goes
to this thing she she takes the
manuscript down to the [ __ ]
Publisher's office and a stalker sees
her and follows her and it's another
he's in love with her oh my God this
dude is such a [ __ ] creep he's got
they won't let her in they won't see her
they're giving her the run around oh
he's too busy to see you girls in your
cookbooks and [ __ ] yeah you ladies and
your lady books yeah
so Mr [ __ ] man who's [ __ ] stalking
her says I had an appointment
but I'm not waiting around for his ass
[ __ ] you can have it because I'm
already a famous author you have my
appointment because he was turns out
later he's a famous children's author
yeah Uncle daddy Uncle Nettie yeah and
he's [ __ ] putting the moves on her
already I mean he takes his she takes
she takes his um
his appointment and gets in there and
the Publisher's like oh man what are you
doing in here you know you girls in your
damn [ __ ] book of poems and [ __ ] man
I got all this you and your feminine
yeah yeah he's like yeah I've got to
print all this [ __ ] for a [ __ ]
the audience you know most of this
shit's junk you know oh you're gonna
like this book and the reason and now
here's the thing the sea captain told
him says you need to look for this
particular dude because he owns a boat
all right and he thinks he's a semen
yeah so you need to find him and show
him the manuscript so she so she says
well I got a book uh it's called blood
and swash that's a it's a it's the
unvarnished life of a sea captain oh
really unvarnished you wrote this he was
like yeah yeah she goes hold on hold on
he starts reading this [ __ ] and he's
going oh okay he's like wait you broke
yes then they go through a montage he go
through a montage because this is the
best book I've ever done he goes now
come on you didn't write this and he
goes no no no no no and he goes
everybody goes I know the captain and
he's like okay you get him
and he said where is he yeah I'd like to
meet him he's like well he's on a long
voyage and he's like okay I see so she
kind of let me let the part she kind of
deceived the publisher to thinking that
this was her boyfriend this captain
yeah which in the way you thought it was
well yeah so
he gives her a [ __ ] great book deal
she was able to save the house yes she
bought she buys it buys the house well
because that was one of his things it's
like well because he died in a stupid
like accidental way he didn't actually
commit suicide which he wanted her to
know because you know it was a point of
Honor even though the way he died was
like actually kind of a stupid accident
which yeah I'm not sure it was much
better people thought people thought he
committed suicide he didn't yeah it was
an accident so um but he was like yeah
what I was planning to do like before I
died in this stupid way was that I was
going to open up this house as like um
you know like a home for a retired semen
like they could come here like in their
old age and they could all live here we
could all hang out and he wanted to do
that so he wanted her to live there and
then like after she like and buy it and
then like after she died she could turn
it into that as well like that would be
in her will no
with all this best-selling book you know
oh Uncle daddy keeps snooping around he
keeps stalking her and [ __ ] while she's
at the beach and making paintings of her
and giving her free paintings and
showing because I'm standing because I
love you oh you're gonna you know all
that kind of [ __ ] and I was like girl oh
my God he's such a creep he's such a
creep well the ghost is seeing this [ __ ]
man he's getting [ __ ] he's getting
he's getting pissed nobody likes Uncle
Nettie even the kid oh by the way her
daughter do you know who that is Natalie
Wood that's Natalie Wood yeah playing
that little girl yeah and the maid like
her maid is just kind of like honey yeah
we've met dude please stay away from
that yeah he's like such as Lee's right
and the ghost the ghost is like
she's she's decided she's going to marry
this dude and a bunch of [ __ ] happens
during that I'm just trying to fast
forward through it through a lot of it
that's all right I don't want to steal
the movie's Thunder yeah because good
[ __ ] I mean it's still worth watching
even if you know what happens in it I
mean because the thing about it is like
this movie is like it's very old it's
like from 1947. and I will note too that
I think in the night late 1960s they
made a TV series of it although they
made it like more a sitcom yeah I
remember which like yeah I mean Nanny
the professor yeah I mean like like I
said this is funny but I don't know if
I'd call it a comedy it's more witty
than funny yeah like I was actually
really impressed by the wittiness of the
script I don't know how much of that
comes from the novel because this was
based on a novel but I mean this like
some of the lines in this I just like
[ __ ] busted up laughing just so so
good like really really clever like the
the way they use language and stuff
eventually what ends up happening is the
cat was like man he's like man this is
we're in a bad situation and you got to
live your life amongst the living I'm
not you know I'm a dead guy I'm a dead
guy and just isn't right type of deal
so he uh
uh did use some kind of psychic force on
her
to make her think that she dreamed all
this and that she wrote that book on her
own through her own imagination that
there that there was never any haunting
and he vanishes he dematerialized he
doesn't come back
until the end all right but [ __ ] he
vanishes he leaves her alone and then
she goes
[ __ ] after Uncle Nettie and [ __ ]
thinking she's going to get married she
tracks down where he lives through the
publisher goes to the house and
knocks on the door he lives in this
[ __ ] big palatial [ __ ] downtown
house you know
and uh it's [ __ ] it's it's laid out
decorated [ __ ] he's definitely like a
millionaire you know
so he knocks on the door and uh she has
to see him and the butler lets her in
and she walks in look at how beautiful
the house is she starts seeing all these
paintings this other woman and [ __ ] this
other woman comes and says oh you're
looking for my husband it turned out
that he was married and he had a couple
kids he had a couple even though he had
told her that he couldn't stand kids
even though he was a children's author
right and then it turned out that Not
only was he already married and had kids
but he had done this before other legs
and other women and I was like see I
told you like that he was a [ __ ]
scumbag you could tell that immediately
because man he was just like he was
playing always up in your [ __ ] space
yeah he was playing he was a total
sleaze yeah so he he was he was amusing
though he was slick but he was he you
could he was uh he was a wolf so anyway
she goes back home
and starts crying and [ __ ] Maids like
it's all right you know he ain't worth
it yeah he definitely wasn't worth it
she starts living her life more towards
raising her daughter and her daughter
goes off to college and comes back and
uh then they're kind of showing the
passage of time that she had this uh
fence post thing stuck out in the ocean
down at the base of the house who had
her name on it had her daughter's name
yeah and every time you'd see it is
looked older and older as time was going
by that was a nice way of doing that I
thought I really liked that yeah and uh
towards the very end she's an old lady
she was out there looking at the ocean
and she goes inside and [ __ ] puts her
shawl around and [ __ ] mate comes
brings her some warm milk she goes oh my
arm's killing me I don't want any warm
milk to happen quit bossing me yeah keep
bossing me around I don't mean a boss
and she runs away and then she's
drinking the milk anyway and puts it
down drops it and dies
and you're like oh man she died and then
you see a hand come down and it's the
captain yeah yeah he comes back for it
yeah what do you say he says he'll never
be tired again yeah because she was
talking about she's like shut up well
because she was old you know what I mean
right you know one of the things that I
really liked about this movie like I
mean her character is so great like I
just I loved her she was just such a
badass
um she was just like I said she was just
not having it she was just very
assertive like I said she wasn't [ __ ]
or nothing like that but she was just
like she was very she was very
self-possessed and she would not let
people push her around yeah and I like
that they gave her a weakness where she
was a little bit of a romantic yeah um
because they even went into the whole
thing like even the even the husband
that she had had that died like prior to
the events of the movie like they even
said it's like well she didn't really
love him like she was fond of him but
she was kind of like she was into the
idea of like the romance kind of angle
and then she was called that right like
he knew because he didn't love him
though she was because no you didn't and
then she was like yeah you're kind of
right yeah yeah he's yeah you know it's
a like I said she said she was fond of
him but yeah I think she that was like I
said that was her flaw was that really
the only one she had was that she had a
little bit she'd get kind of Carried
Away by like a romantic notion and then
would get herself in and the same thing
happened with like the uncle Nettie [ __ ]
face yeah where he was clearly a sleaze
I mean very very clearly and a stalker
and a weirdo but because he was coming
on so strong and it's like there was a
couple things that happened that were
like romantic to her that red is
romantic so she kind of like got in on
even though sick every single other
person like her daughter her maid the
ghost everybody like that they were just
saying oh my God that guy is such a
scumbag but she just didn't want to hear
it well the captain and Uncle Nettie
were exact opposites yeah Uncle Nettie
had a real polished upper class educated
way about himself he was a sleaze bag
yeah sales had a lot of money the
captain had a real rough exterior you
know what I mean but the thing is is
that he was actually real educated and
cultured and was a good guy and he's a
good dude he was a good guy yeah he was
loyal even though he swore a lot and
stuff like that well because that was
the awesome thing about him was that
even though he didn't like it when she
was hanging out with uncle Nettie and
being like yeah he's a scumbag and he
was jealous
but he realized it's like look I'm dead
and she's alive and she needs to make
her own decisions and she needs to make
her own way in life and me being here is
interfering with that so he loved her
enough to step off and just say I'm just
gonna make you think that I was just a
dream because I'm [ __ ] up your life
yeah see the captain lived a full life
all right and I think he died older than
you see him you know he appears you know
as Rex Harrison he's probably in his 50s
but I have a feeling he was more like in
his 70s when he died
yeah
because he said he lived a full life and
I don't I think dying at 50s probably
wouldn't be considered a full life then
no not really yeah not even not even
back then so
um I think he was uh so he lived a full
life he had a life of adventure out on a
sea
he had a lot of women okay yeah he was a
hoe at his at his death there were he
had three girlfriends showed up mourning
him but he was married
but the thing with him is that he never
had true love really yeah he's deployed
all the time he was gone yeah so it
wasn't possible
and it seems kind of like for her she
had all these guys
you know she was you know they're
interested in her but she didn't no real
true love really
none of that happened until after they
were reunited in death it's a nice scene
it was I thought it was a really nice
ending because I was kind of hoping that
that would happen you know because the
cap and the cap and before the captain
leaves her you know uh dematerialized
forever and makes her forget
he just said that look at what we missed
we missed out on something yeah because
we were born at different times yeah
right yeah well the cool thing about her
too and another thing that I liked about
this movie is that
you know after Uncle Nettie like [ __ ]
her over and she finds out that he's
married and that like he's done it
before and stuff like that she basically
is like yeah [ __ ] all this man [ __ ]
and she just like goes and essentially
becomes a recluse I mean she loves her
house
um her maid stays with her and she still
like has contact with her daughter but I
like that they didn't make her
they didn't make her seem like an old
maid you know what I mean yeah like they
didn't make it seem
like overly sad because I feel like what
they would do in a lot of these kind of
stories is that like if the woman got
like [ __ ] over by the man like when
because she wasn't really that old
and then it's like oh just I'm gonna
become a recluse forever you know what I
mean and she did but it wasn't seen as
like a failing necessarily she was just
kind of like well that's I'm I'm closing
up shop or whatever and she just seemed
content like not necessarily like happy
but she seemed content with her life the
way it was like she lived kind of
isolated she just lived with her maid
and like you know her daughter went off
to college and then her daughter would
come and her daughter got married and
had a kid and and she like had so she
had a family and stuff but she knew that
I think she got to a point where and
maybe I'm reading too much into the
character but I think I got she got to a
point where she realized oh my like
overly romantic Notions or I'm I keep
getting into these bad situations with
these dudes because it happened with her
husband and it happened with Uncle
Nettie and she's like yeah I'm just
gonna knock that off and maybe I'll just
wait maybe she hoped you know just all
just wait until I'm dead and then
hopefully like that'll work out because
that was like the one one thing but yeah
so it's kind of like it was a happy
ending but it's like a little bit
Bittersweet too but I guess they got
together in there if I cried if I watch
it again uh no but you get choked up at
the end he did say yeah
because it is like a really nice yeah
because you really build you up to it
yeah you know because you're rooting for
them
yeah because even though they're like
total opposite I don't even know if I'd
say their total opposite no they're a
lot more similar than they think they
are they were both Romantics yeah yeah
they both work even though like I guess
it's kind of manifested itself in a
different way but they both were well he
was all romantic about the sea and [ __ ]
you know what I mean yeah which and it
was all uh you know [ __ ] dangerous uh
independent
[ __ ] rugged masculinity and then you
had uh she was very feminine and uh uh
caring and really you know she's carried
about you know how he grew up and you
know just you know it was just it was
just they were kind of a good match and
he cared about her
Okay and like I said he he loved her
enough to let her yeah live her own life
and make her own mistakes because he
even told her like look I'm dead it's
like you know you need to get out there
and live and go see men and so like like
yeah he got jealous about it because he
loved her but he understood that it
wasn't gonna work out you know because
she was alive and he was dead and he
didn't want to deprive her yeah of
living a life like he had because he
said that uh nothing he says where he
goes uh nothing more can happen for me
it's all over yeah basically but the
thing is is that he was a ghost right he
was kind of like EarthBound
until the very end they leave together
yeah into the into the after world
I get yeah I guess they want they want
to kind of Heaven I mean I thought that
was the implication but yeah I mean well
that's the thing I think one of the
first things that endeared her to him at
the beginning like because this reminded
me of that when you were talking about
them both being Romantics yeah was that
she said one of the things that appealed
to her at first about the house like why
she wanted it so bad is that because she
felt like the house almost like it was
alive or like it needed her help you
know what I mean and so she saw it as
almost like a living thing like that she
needed to help out and then when she
said that to him he said oh I guess
that's not silly because I've heard this
I've I had the same thing about a ship
in particular that I came across that
looked kind of shitty but he's like I
always felt like it it was still twice
that it would sail twice as sweet for me
as I would for somebody else because he
took care of it and so they had kind of
that similar thing going on so I kind of
feel like that was and like I said I
liked I think that he liked that she was
kind of salty and like didn't let him
yeah boss or like push her she started
cussing too every now and then and that
was like super funny and it was like
funny too because like she said she'd do
it in the street like not swearing
swearing like yeah
and that was it like I said that was
cussing back then like women were like
if a woman do that they'd be like oh my
God you know so it's just like it's
funny that
it's just you know it seems like nothing
nowadays but back in the day like you
had to be very very ladylike and you
couldn't say like certain words and
everything like that Richard Brown said
have you seen a Blythe Spirit
um I have I saw it when I was a kid but
I haven't seen it since then and
interestingly when we watched this last
night we rented it on Amazon Prime
um blind Spirit was like the next movie
that came up like to rent because Rex
Harrison is also in that
um somebody said Rex Harrison was like
the most hated man in Hollywood I heard
I don't know how true this is but yeah
he was
um interesting they got him to play this
part because he was a little bit of a um
a womanizer in real life and I think
there was I can't remember the name of
the actress but I think he had an affair
with an actress at one point and she
like committed suicide at some point
like after yeah so I think after that
happened everybody kind of like cooled
on him a little bit but you know I don't
know like I don't know like all the
details but
that's uh yeah that might be why and let
me see uh they're talking about The
Uninvited which is another one yeah
that's another one we have to do because
a lot of people
um have like uh recommended that one I
thought we saw that one not that black
cover with the damn devil face on it
well there's more than one movie called
that okay like ooh sexbot sexbots coming
in there mango says Carol Landis was the
actress that's right I knew that I had
heard somebody talking about it earlier
today because I was watching another
interview like another uh review of this
but I couldn't remember what her name
was
flasher friend said in the 70s there was
a comedy series called Ghostbusters that
was kind of like 70s Abbott Costello
type show where he had these two ghost
exterminators with their pet gorilla I
kind of remember that I kind of remember
that
um yeah but yeah so I mean if you like
anything
I don't know like I said I I do like
ghost you know that movie was talking
about ghost in there yeah I I like that
movie I saw in the theater and
everything like that but I don't know I
like I think I liked this one more just
because
I don't know I just really there was
something really witty about it like the
character interactions were really good
tone is very different though it is yeah
well because I feel like ghost was more
that's more like a murder mystery yeah
too also a lot more modern the telling
this is like classic theater yeah this
is very very Golden Age Hollywood and it
looks beautiful like the cinematography
I think that the effects in there the
cinematography got uh an Oscar
nomination or maybe an Oscar win oh and
Bernard Herman did the score for this uh
the guy that did psycho you know what I
mean yeah among many other things uh and
I think that he's got a record of saying
this was his favorite score it's very
very Lush
they spent a lot of time up in the
Captain's Room and it has a balcony with
a telescope looking out of there
and um the it's got glass doors like uh
that can that can close it off and in a
lot of scenes this is in the background
and you see seagulls flying by like
you're really in a real location and
it's and then at night there's a moon
you know over the water with clouds but
it's got to be back projection I'm not
sure because the thing about it I mean
this movie the the novel was set in
England and this is also supposed to be
set in England like the seaside but
obviously they shot it in California
yeah so I don't really know it has some
British people in it I think yeah I mean
they did shoot this in a real house like
I don't think that was a set necessarily
I don't know how they got those seagulls
to fly around
maybe they just were feeding the
seagulls the seagulls were flying around
but I was trying to like I was trying to
like watch it and be like now is that
the same footage of the seagulls like
you know what I mean like is it on a
loop but I could have maybe it was maybe
it was real sequels I couldn't tell I
thought it was more more likely that it
was some kind of projection back there
and they're projecting those that's kind
of what I thought but I'm not really
sure because they were just getting
beautiful shots in the background the
seagulls coming up behind them and stuff
out the window man there was just one
thing I noticed was like the the
cinematography in this was like so so
beautiful it was just like so crisp and
like so just really really nice some of
the shots out of that balcony in the bay
with the damn Moonlight and the [ __ ]
at night with the damn clouds I don't
think they could have got a shot like
that back in 47.
it's a nighttime shot you see out in the
background it's kind of had to be some
some kind of projection
I mean I really liked really lightning
and [ __ ] happens yeah and I like the
scenes too like or this might be what
you're talking about but like early on
where she comes down to the kitchen and
like you know the ghost before before
he's revealed like before she sees him
she's heard him so she knows he's in
there but like she comes down to the
kitchen and she's trying to light the
the lights and she's trying to light the
thing to boil for the um for the you
know hot water thing the what do they
call that thing uh well hot water bottle
right the hot water bottle yeah I
couldn't remember the words
this is maybe it's really maybe it's
gold people did that I guess they put a
hot water bottle in bed with them yeah
yeah she did that and I had never seen a
hot one because nowadays you see those
like rubber ones yeah but back then it
looked like a little glass bottle
wouldn't it it was it glass it was
covered with like it looked like it was
covered with fabric it was nice but it
was kind of like oval like a big like a
Faberge egg or something did you poured
like boiling water in it but this the
scene where she goes down there to do
that and she knows the ghost is in the
room because she's heard him and he's
like [ __ ] around and he keeps blowing
the pilot light out or he keeps blowing
the candles out and she's like hey can I
just like boil someone like what the
[ __ ] you know what I mean and the just
the way they shot that was like really
really nice it's like all the blacks
were like really really
like deep and then like the little bit
of light here a little bit of light
there and then finally he's just like
revealed they don't do anything cheesy
like he doesn't like dematerialize that
if he's usually just kind of like he's
there like a regular person the camera
angles right and then like she'll just
like turn around and then she turns back
yeah he's gone when she first meets him
and they cut the deal he's like okay I'm
gonna stay confined to the bedroom up
there because I'll just you guys can
have the recipe yeah I'll stand there
and I'll just like watch you undress all
the time
so what happened was is that he says
we're going to stay I'll just stay up
there in that room and she's well where
am I going to stay he was in the master
bedroom he's like what because I don't
have a body I don't have a body and
she's like yeah but she's still got eyes
so later on that night later on that
night she they show her
stepping away from the dresser she's in
her bed clothes and she gets into bed
and you hear his voice because before
your boys say don't ever let anyone tell
you to be ashamed of your figure
see like I said that'd be a little bit
creepy like thinking that there was like
a ghost like oh it's like watching you
all the time she's like why do you watch
me when I'm in the can it's like you
know what I mean where am I gonna stay
in the master bedroom yeah she's like
but but because she was like I mean she
was scared because it was a ghost but
then she was just kind of like
um she's like yeah I know you're in here
and it's like I thought it was neat that
it was hot and everything she basically
was like well just don't show yourself
to my daughter because she's too young
and I don't want her to get scared so he
agreed to do that at least you know what
I mean but yeah but then it turns out
later towards the very end before she
dies
turns out that the daughter had been
talking to the captain she thought it
was a dream but she figured it was the
same way yeah and and the and and uh the
maid too he was friends with the maid
and her daughter behind her back
she didn't find until the very end they
were seeing him also he was talking to
him
now wait did did the maid see him base
yeah because remember when she I mean I
know the daughter did yeah because she
came out later inside in three or four
different places in the first of all she
wanted to pitch her and then she said a
captain's more my more my that's true
the cat was more on my speed and she's
talking about because somebody said hey
somebody made some kind of off-headed
remark about you you need to go down
here maybe you can uh what was it
see lieutenant or something might meet a
might meet a good looking Lieutenant
that's what they told the yeah the man
goes nah Captain's one of my style yeah
basically
because she she had been
talking to the captain but he made them
all forget
but they kind of remembered the the Mind
wipes didn't work well he didn't do a
complete mind wave he basically just
made them think that they had dreamed it
yeah but
the daughter and the maid kind of
thought it was real
they started suspect it started to
suspect later and evidently so did Mrs
Muir because when she found out that the
daughter had been talking to the captain
she was kind of like no we just dreamed
she said no we didn't drink you think we
just dreamed it and she was like uh
they didn't dream it yeah but that's
yeah
they do kind of leave it ambiguous with
the maid but yeah she did make a couple
of yeah
he was helping her
because it would be pretty hard because
the thing about it is that he wasn't shy
about doing the haunting you know what I
mean because if you remember the scene
where
um the where Lucy's Mrs Muir's
mother-in-law and the sister-in-law come
to the house to tell her that the gold
mine has dried up and it's like oh you
should move back in with us because now
you're broke
um and then the ghost threw the ladies
out of the house like bodily they
couldn't see him but they could feel
that you know he was shoving them out
the house yeah and the little girl saw
that yeah like saw what happened I don't
know if she could see him but she saw
she said she saw him what what had
happened I think she said she said she'd
see him and talk to him remember yeah
but no I'm just saying I don't know if
she saw him like that particular time
yeah but she said like later on when she
was grown up she was telling her mom
that she had seen him and talked to him
like all the time you know what I mean
yeah I was reading stories or something
singing songs I don't remember what it
was yeah yeah Tom psych says where did
this film take place like I said it's
supposed to be the first part of it is
supposed to be London and then because
that's where she's was living like when
her husband died and then she moves out
here to like a seaside village
essentially
um it's like I said it's supposed to be
England but they shot it in California
it's an American movie yeah but you know
it's not a British actors so so it
doesn't it doesn't look look like yeah
the UK no but a lot of the character
actors they I think they were British
like the guys the publishing agents well
Rex Harrison was British for sure
um I thought Gene Tierney was American
but I'm not entirely sure of that but
I'm almost 99. yeah Mrs Muir doesn't
speak with a British accent she speaks
to transatlantic and like they did back
in the
in the 40s all your actors all your
actors and actresses spoke transatlantic
American English it was a fake accent
just for announcers and [ __ ]
yeah I guess they wanted everybody to
like sound like
which is really interesting that they
didn't want people having particular
they did the thing the same thing in the
UK too where they wanted everybody to
have just like a generic yeah kind of
accent they didn't really want anybody
to have their yeah the accents of where
they came from what's funny is that
transatlantic never existed it was a
generic American accent that you that
would that could be understood anywhere
in the United States this is in a time
when
the regional accents between north and
south and west and the East and Midwest
I mean they were obvious I mean you know
some of the stuff up in New England is
still just [ __ ] crazy ass accents
when I hear it
um but transatlantic was very neutral
and yeah that was the point of it I
guess that was the point of it but
what's funny is that
I was listening to
voice recordings this is years back
of accounts from Confederate officers
about things that happened during
certain battles and it was in the
original southern accent sounded like
transatlantic it wasn't this there was
no Southern drawl
sound like transatlantic and it was in
its Day thought to sound British it
sounded just like something out of
Fallout like all the little you know
like the little uh
little storyline things even the Fallout
video game like a little propaganda
films yeah like that just sounded just
like that and it's just uh when you
think of like a Civil War era
Southerners in movies they gave them
strong Southern Accents but that's not
how the officers sounded
it's weird
didn't expect it you can look it up on
YouTube there they're there
sounds like something out of damn
Fallout the way accents change over time
is very very interesting to me I always
thought that was interesting but yeah I
mean
because the The Source novel for this
movie uh which came out in 1945 it was
set in England and it was an English
writer named Josephine Leslie who wrote
the book
so um I don't even think it had been
published in the United States until the
rights to it were bought and then the
movie came out
but yeah so it was supposed to be
England but
well I mean they they specifically said
when she went to like the publisher and
stuff like that that was London right
they did specifically say yeah it was
London so they did like specifically but
obviously they shot it in California so
and it's pretty it's pretty clear that
it's California like when do you see the
movie but you know that's okay whatever
it doesn't really matter like where it
takes place to be honest with you
um let's see yeah uh yeah Samantha said
Natalie Wood was a little girl yep she
that's the thing like she um
she wasn't in it a great deal though
you know what I mean yeah she's it's a
bit part yeah it's just it's just a very
small bit part because I was pretty sure
that that was Natalie Wood but she
wasn't in it enough to really
uh you know to see if that was like
actually her because I was just kind of
like well I'm pretty sure that's Natalie
Wood but you're not really seeing it
because she's not really the focus of
the story you know Samantha's seen it
she's talking about
when she lights the candle in the
kitchen and he appears yeah she turns
around like that and he's standing in
the corner with his arms crossed looking
at her
yeah and like I said I mean it's very
effective it is very effective and and
as I said I really like her character
because she conveys very well that it's
like yeah that would be scary if he saw
a [ __ ] ghost like so even though she
knew that there was a ghost in the house
because she'd heard him and stuff like
laughing and whatnot
but seeing it in front of you that would
be pretty scary and you can tell that
she's scared but she's also not willing
to like let this you know because she's
kind of like oh [ __ ] you know what I
mean sits down she goes give me a few
minutes to get to get used to you like
yeah and then she just like starts
talking to him like a regular person so
I was like I don't know I just really
really liked that I liked that they that
she was allowed to like be scared of him
because you would be but then she
basically said yeah I'm not scared of
you you know what I mean so yeah I mean
I don't know this was just a really
really good movie and like I said I
don't think
I thought that I had seen it when I was
a kid
but I only remembered like a little like
little fragments of it so maybe I didn't
maybe I didn't see the whole thing
straight through but yeah I mean this is
absolutely I just I I thought it was
delightful I thought it was delightful I
mean it just has a has a just a great
script great characters it's just it
looks beautiful like the score is
awesome it's just like a it's just a
really fun yeah movie it's just really
really entertaining this is the kind of
movie where you don't want them to
reboot or to re-release or do again this
is the one you see like you don't need
to remake this movie you just see the
original yeah they don't they were I you
know what they were thinking about doing
it in the 90s but they never got around
to it I thought Sean Connery was gonna
be it makes more sense in this format in
the 40s 1947 format yeah you know that
that's it because it's very theatrical
but it's still very effective theater
and and and good film you know they
where they shot things and the
transitions the edits really good so you
know no just leave it alone man it's a
masterpiece okay it is of what it is
yeah I mean I don't really know if like
I I like the idea of it like I said
they've done other movies like this yeah
they did ghosts they did another movie
like I said with Alan Rickman called
Truly Madly Deeply which was similar in
the fact that it was like a living
person that fell in love with a ghost so
they've done that before and like I said
they did this as a sitcom but with uh
hope Lang in it I think but it's like I
I don't remember seeing that I remember
hearing about it but I don't remember
saying it's a sitcom of this I saw it
all the time when I was kid was it all
right it was more of like it was more
funny yeah this is funny but it's more
like clever funny it's more like witty
funny you're never really under the
impression that the guy's a ghost anyway
really well when you're a kid you're
watching it and you're like yeah okay
whatever it reminded me very much of
like nanny the professor yeah that's
what it reminded me which I think I
remember being a kid like a nanny and
the professor better
yeah now I'm kind of like curious to see
those two things let's see but I just
like I thought it was kind of cool that
I don't know I thought I think it's kind
of cool that this is one of your
favorite movies yeah yeah I saw when I
was a kid this is an awesome movie it's
awesome yeah yeah I really like it a lot
yeah it's a good Gothic paranormal
romance yeah it's a good way to put it
but it's a kind of Adventure in it
comedy too you know it's it's just yeah
like I said it's just an all-around like
entertaining it's just delightful it's a
delightful delightful movie I mean I
just I had a great time theme is true
love that's the theme yeah all right
yeah
Hugo says I'm gonna try and watch it
tonight couldn't find it yesterday
didn't know it was on Amazon yeah you
can rent it on um if this is the movie
that you're talking about you can rent
it on Amazon Prime or you can rent it on
YouTube YouTube and it's 3.99 yeah it is
worth it it's worth it that's what we
did easily Tom Sykes says are the
practical effects good in this film yeah
they don't yeah they are they don't use
a lot
um very tasty but yeah they don't it
doesn't like detract from the story or
anything because like I said when you
see the ghost he usually just he looks
like a regular guy yeah the ghost is
revealed through regular
practical camera edit yeah just the way
it is you you'll see it yeah you'll see
it with the
good score behind it
yeah
everything is very effective
you know yeah and it's classy
yeah it's that's a good word it is a
very classy very classy class classy
film oh and I was gonna say the costume
design is great too yeah I love like all
the dresses that they put on Gene
Tierney they look amazing I heard I was
watching another uh review of this I
heard that she broke her foot before
they did the shooting of this so they
had to do all the scenes of her sitting
down first like until you know what I
mean so I guess like in the later scenes
where you see her walking around I guess
they did those later and she was like
limping and stuff yeah Pat says uh I
think it was on at the same time as
Nanny and the professor by the way I
agree Nanny the professor was better
okay yeah I like an Indian Professor
better and I liked uh all what was the
one um
wasn't All in the Family what's the name
of that [ __ ] the other one they had
Bill Bixby in it
and um he it was he was raising his son
his wife had died and there was a oh I
know what you're talking about a nanny
that was like a nanny that was helping
him yeah I like that one too God damn it
what the [ __ ] was the name of that [ __ ]
I know what you're talking about
he used to be my best friend
he rose with you remember the theme song
yeah yeah I know what you're talking
about but I can't remember the name of
it yeah I forgot what that I think I saw
that yeah [ __ ] million years yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah now like to the 70s like
tonight we should do like a we should go
down a YouTube rabbit hole of like all
the Forgotten 60s and 70s yeah because
I'm sure there's probably a lot that
like I saw back in the day that I
totally and then one called Eight is
Enough came out after that yeah yeah I
remember that one that was kind of
amusing the one I really dug though man
by the time I was about 12 was Facts of
Life I had all the girls I loved facts
yeah I had a crush on all those girls
Joe was the [ __ ] I had a crush on all of
them I love Joe I also love Natalie yeah
like Natalie was cool too and 2D was
cool too I like that she had lights and
and Blair and Blair was a [ __ ] but she
was kind of a cool [ __ ] I thought she
was cute and then she was cute who was
the one uh who was the one that was the
Tomboy Joe Joe yeah she was my favorite
yeah yeah she was a badass it was Blair
and Joe I thought were the cutest one
yeah well they were kind of like the
main character like I said you had
Natalie and 2D and all them too so wait
were there there were other ones too
weren't there yeah I feel like those
were the four main ones though yeah
Toady was um
the black girl
didn't she wear roller skates all the
time Duty yeah I think so she was the
one with the roller skates right yeah
it's been a while yeah so I mean that
was 80s yeah 80s and they were teenagers
themselves I think
yeah they were playing teenagers I think
they were teenagers yeah we should do it
we should do a live stream where we
watch the [ __ ] Facts of Life
Facts of Life I remember yeah I was like
12. I remember really get that too do
you remember there was one called
um what the [ __ ] was the name of that
one that had the guy uh that was like a
it was like a building super like the
courtship of Eddie's Father oh yeah yeah
that's right that's what that [ __ ]
show was called with buildings that's
right the courtship of Eddie's father
was a stupid title for it but that's
just that's what it was called
that was a weird that was a good that
was a good series I remember liking that
one yeah kind of iconic yeah that show
yeah Pat's just came up with it Pat just
came out okay
that's right yeah I totally forgotten
yeah
John Gore says after falling for the
ghost Mrs Muir can't go back to normal
life even though the ghost tries to
force her back by disappearing
yeah I mean that's the thing
no she went back to normal life she did
but she basically just said she didn't
have a very good normal life after that
done though yeah it was early 1900s and
she was a widow yeah yeah their
prospects weren't good
but but the thing about it was that she
was just kind of like I well like I said
I liked it in the movie that she was
just kind of like after Uncle Nettie
[ __ ] her over she was just kind of
like yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm just
gonna like if I can't have the sea
captain yeah then I'm just gonna like
say [ __ ] it and just live in my
wonderful house with my maid and not
yeah I can't watch the kids grab there
was there was no dating then they didn't
do that yeah but I like that they didn't
make that like they didn't make her seem
like a saddle no old bat or anything
like that like she seemed like pretty
contented just being kind of isolated
and I was like that's kind of awesome
she the cab didn't really he really
didn't have anything to lose I mean he
was dead he was outside of the
space-time Continuum for him he just
fast forwarded until she croaked
several minutes I see what you like
after you die
he was waiting on her I was kind of
wondering though like I guess he knew
how it works because he'd been dead for
a while but I was kind of wondering this
did actually cross my mind like when she
died at the end he's like oh [ __ ] is she
gonna like stay looking like a super old
woman it's like or is she gonna go back
to being like young and hot again no
when you when when you die you go back
to how you imagine yourself at your
Prime yeah well I guess he already knew
that so he was just kind of like he knew
he sits why he said you'll never be
tired again now come on Lucia that's
that's what he called her yeah
that's like pretty awesome this is an
awesome movie it's an awesome movie I
mean you know yeah it's like a movie
version of the day I'm [ __ ] uh aha
video Take On Me
but with no comic books no yeah
it is kind of like that
all right are we uh ready to wrap it up
all right so tomorrow is Wednesday and
that means that that's our main show
we're gonna be doing some UFO action
we're going to be talking about the
Stardust Ranch okay I don't know that
one so uh so yeah we'll see we'll see
how that goes but that was the one that
won so that's what we're gonna be
talking about tomorrow so you should
have a good time with that because you
like UFO shows yeah so uh thank you
everybody for dropping by this evening
and talking about this cool ass movie
please go watch it because it's really
really good if you haven't seen it and
we will see you guys again tomorrow
evening
good night